he's a hero boov now so that's why that
character's voice sounded so familiar
some of the most famous singers in the
world have lent their voice to big
screen animated characters
and you might not have even realized it
these singers are incredibly talented
but
even so voice acting is a completely
different
beast of vocal talents however if anyone
has the dedication to hone this skill
it's these pop stars let's see who spent
time as an animated character
the interesting cow rihanna is one of
the most popular singers today
but she has also dabbled in voice work
you can hear her
in the 2015 animated film home as main
character gratuity tip
tucci it was her first ever voice over
role for an animated character and she
had to learn some new tricks for the
part
one thing in particular she had to learn
to do was speak in an american accent
for the role
she actually stated in an interview from
2012
that she's not very good at doing other
accents
it seems as if she's come a long way
since then as her american accent is
pretty good in the movie
the interrupting cow
cameron first appeared in the marvel
universe as ruby in agents of shield
in 2018 she joined another marvel
project
the marvel rising series and provided
voice work for the character gwen stacy
and ghost spider
everyone's so caught up in dishing out
punishment they never
stopped to ask me if i was actually
guilty cameron is a fan of gwen stacy
and was excited to portray the character
she explained that there was a lot more
physical action while recording
than one might think you move a lot
actually
to kind of like feign the action there's
a lot more action than you guys think
oh no no no my name is gwen and i'm
trying to be a hero like you two
you probably know selena from her time
on the disney channel
along with her extremely popular music
career
you can also catch selena doing voice
work for all three hotel transylvania
movies
as main character mavis i love you dad
but we don't even know if the kid's
gonna be a vampire
she said in an interview that recording
her part was a bit difficult
due to her being a very emotive person
and obviously
when you're voice acting the only thing
that matters are the vocals
not expressions selena will be reprising
her role again
in the upcoming fourth hotel
transylvania film as she continues to
prove herself
as an all-around talent holy rabies
this looks like a blast katy perry made
her animated voice
acting debut in 2011's the smurfs
she played smurfette starring alongside
super talents
such as neil patrick harris and hank
azaria
that means you're just like me perry
said that she needed to create depth in
her voicings
to fit the nature of the depth of the
character her performance was
clearly well received as she reprised
her role in the sequel two years later
it doesn't matter where you came from
did you know
taylor swift voiced a main character in
dr seuss's the lorax
she provided her vocals for audrey the
girl next door to zac
efron's ted oh i could kiss you right
now swift said she
jumped at the opportunity to be in the
movie and shared that dr
seuss's books were her first exposure to
poetry
you can make words absolutely bounce off
of a page this may mean
that without dr seuss we would have
never gotten taylor's singing career
it's taylor's only voice acting credit
but we think she has the talent to take
on more roles
they used to grow all around here ariana
grande has some incredible vocal talent
and in 2013 she lent those vocals to the
animated film
underdogs where she played main
character laura
the movie is actually an argentinian
film that got a us release in 2014.
the us version is where you can hear
grande as she provides the english dub
for her character
it's not an extremely well-known role of
grandes
but it was still nice to see the
talented pop star
trying different avenues of
entertainment you think there's nothing
in the world you can't own
the 2015 film home features some
big-name celebrities
including the previously mentioned
rihanna among these big names
is jennifer lopez who voiced lucy so
tell me where she is or find me a boo
who can
this isn't her first time as an animated
character as she also played sabertooth
tiger shira
in ice age continental drift for home
lopez
also lent her singing voice for the
original song feel the light
which peaked at number 16 on the
billboard hot 100
lopez explained the difficulties of
having to voice act
it's hard you know when you're just
trying to put a performance
all through your voice it's not as easy
as it sounds
she adjusted nicely to this way of
acting and gave a
solid performance as lucy we're from
barbados we don't have snow
shakira didn't have a large role in
zootopia
but she did have a memorable one she
played gazelle
an extremely famous pop star that seemed
to be modeled off of shakira herself
she sang the original song try
everything which can be heard a couple
of times throughout the movie
shakira explained the difference of
recording a song for a movie
opposed to for her album and the song
already comes with images it comes
hand-in-hand with them
shakira has been a fan of disney movies
for a long time
so getting the opportunity to play a
disney character
is something she loved doing she
actually brags to her son about the
connection she has with mickey mouse now
i won't give up no i won't give him
queen bee beyonce can be seen playing an
animated queen
in the 2013 movie epic as queen tara
mob grub it's a very nice looking group
of pods
beyonce talked about how the process of
creating an animated movie
surprised and interested her and how she
has always wanted to voice an animated
character
she also explained how the performance
actually felt natural to her
due to her career as a singer i am used
to
singing and kind of having to get my
message and my emotion across
through song without a visual this
wouldn't be her last voice acting role
either
as she would voice nala in the 2019
disney live action remake of the lion
king
with a track record like that we
wouldn't be surprised if we see her in
more animated features down the road
how about that one katy perry isn't the
only pop star on this list to voice
smurfette
demi lovato also voiced the role in
smurf's
lost village the third film in the
franchise
even though lovato hadn't done voice
work for an animated character
previously
she was excited to take the role part of
the reason for this
is because she didn't think that voicing
the character would be hard work
it doesn't take a lot of a ton of hard
work to voice such a cute character
who do you think played the better
smurfette perry or lovato
we're smurfs we do the right thing
tangled is one of disney's most popular
animated films
a big reason for this was the character
rapunzel
who was very memorable the character was
voiced by mandy moore
who sang all of the original songs for
the princess
too weak to handle myself out there huh
mother
the song i see the light which was a
duet between
moore and her co-star zachary levi hit
number one on the billboard hot 100
charts
the song also won a grammy for best song
written specifically for a motion
picture
which is even more proof that more was
perfect for the part
she gave a great all-around performance
and later reprised her role of rapunzel
as a cameo in ralph breaks the internet
the paint made from the white shells you
once brought me
will i am voices the hilarious moto moto
in madagascar escape to africa
the character is remembered for his deep
sultry voice
will said that that was his ladies man
voice
will also recorded multiple songs for
the movie including the oddly catchy
big and chunky that we hear when
motomoto meets gloria
william brought this character to life
and turned a
secondary character into the showstopper
that everyone would remember
girl you plump him one of timberlake's
credits on his long and impressive
resume
is his voice work in the trolls movies
i'm not going to your party
this is not the first time timberlake
has voiced an animated character though
he played arthur in shrek iii and booboo
in yogi bear
his experience shows as he delivers a
well-rounded performance in both trolls
films
he also sang multiple songs for the
movie including the original hit
can't stop the feeling which hit number
one on the billboard hot 100.
timberlake continues to prove he can do
it all
there will be no more scrapbooking
the disney channel star turned pop star
is no stranger to the house of mouse
she played penny the owner of the
titular dog in disney's bolt
cyrus also sang the original song i
thought i lost you which was nominated
for a golden globe award for best
original song
in 2008 this is miley's only voice
acting credit for an animated character
maybe we'll see her voice and animated
character again
someday soon yeah you're my good boy
when you make a movie titled sing it's
probably a smart idea to bring in some
real singers for the cast
which is exactly what they did tori
kelly plays mina
a shy elephant with an incredible voice
she recorded
several songs for her character with her
powerful voice taking the character to a
whole other level
i mean yes yeah i can sing kelly
explained that she enjoyed the voice
acting process
particularly that she didn't have to
prepare physically for the role
a big highlight is definitely getting to
roll in your sweats
and just not worry about what you look
like at all
sounds like a good deal to us i was laid
back
very chill we have to give a ton of
credit to these artists
it can be scary and challenging to try
something as difficult as voice acting
these singers prove that their vocal
talents stretch beyond just
music we're sure zendaya has put in the
work to voice lola bunny in space jam a
new legacy
which singer do you think did the best
voice acting job